chers collègues merci de merci de nous
d'être présent parce que c'est quand
même une réunion un peu importe
dans les annonces paroissiales on a dû
vous faire passer le l'agenda
prévisionnel des auditions puisqu'on va
rentrer évidemment dans le cycle des
auditions budgétaires chaque année
lorsque les feuilles commencent à tomber
et
par ailleurs j'ai dû signer hier des
invitations qui vous sont adressées pour
deux missions de déplacement sur des
bases
voilà les capacités de l'armée de terre
ça c'est assez habituel et puis le salon
ironaval vous répondrez c'est toujours
intéressant
de nous y retrouver de la même manière
je le dis pour ceux que ça concerne
j'aurai l'occasion de réunir un bureau
de la commission pour
lancer un petit peu les opérations sur
2023 l'émission etc etc
alors nous allons donc procéder à
l'audition de Rémy Riou dont la
nomination par le Président de la
République
est envisagé
a été décidé plus exactement pour
exercer une troisième fois les fonctions
de directeur général de l'AFD et donc en
application de l'article 13 alinéa 5 de
la Constitution cette nomination ne peut
intervenir qu'après l'audition du
candidat devant les commissions
compétentes de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat audition qui doit être
immédiatement suivie d'un vote alors les
modalités de cette audition et du vote
ont été précisées par la loi organique
du 23 juillet 2010 et la loi ordinaire
de la même date il est ainsi donc prévu
dans ce texte que l'audition est
publique elle fait l'objet d'une
captation audiovisuelle et nous l'avons
également ouvert à la presse
à l'issue de cette audition nous allons
procéder au vote qui va se dérouler à
bulletin secret comme le prévoit
l'article 19 bis de notre règlement
en application de la loi du 23 juillet
2010 il ne peut y avoir de délégation de
vote
il ne peut y avoir de délégation de
votre donc ceux qui seront pas là ne
peuvent pas donner pouvoir à quiconque
et le dépouillement doit être effectué
simultanément à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat je vous rappelle enfin que
l'article 13 de la Constitution dispose
que le Président de la République ne
pourrait procéder à cette nomination si
l'addition des votes négatives de chaque
commission représentait au moins 3/5 des
suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions
à l'issue de cette audition je
demanderai aux personnes extérieures à
notre commission de bien vouloir quitter
la salle afin que nous puissions
procéder au vote nous pourrons
dépouiller le scrutin simultanément avec
l'Assemblée nationale après notre vote
je rappelle qu'en fait l'Assemblée
nationale a eu sa séance la semaine
dernière et que l'urne a été mis sous
scellé et que donc le dépouillement va
intervenir pour respecter strictement
les textes
oui mais je suis désolé je suis en train
le règlement du Sénat prévoit qu'un
rapporteur doit être nommé dans le cadre
de cette procédure de nomination de
l'article 13 de la Constitution afin de
présenter le candidat et de l'interroger
je vous propose de nommer nos
rapporteurs développement c'est-à-dire
huxori Rachid themal nos habituels
spécialistes de l'aide au développement
avant de faire entrer monsieur Riou pour
son audition je vous rappelle que nous
l'avons déjà auditionné deux fois
puisque c'est le deuxième renouvellement
c'est la troisième fois qui va exercer
qu'il souhaite exercer ce mandat il est
venu devant notre commission expliquer
sa vision de l'agence rendre compte de
ses activités
je souhaite souligner que la rapides
augmentation des engagements de la FD je
rappelle qu'en 2019 ces engagements
étaient montés à 14 milliards d'euros et
un certain flottement dans la
gouvernance de la politique de
développement nous ont parfois conduit à
manifester notre insatisfaction vous
aurez évidemment la parole pour vous
exprimer sur ces sujets si vous le
souhaitez
l'augmentation constante des engagements
de la FD dans les pays émergents dont la
Turquie et la Chine a aussi suscité des
interrogations vous souvenez de ce
document qui présentait les deux
développements et où en tête de en tête
de gondole on voyait la Chine et la
Chine et la Turquie ce qui paraissait
quand même assez étonnant l'audition
d'aujourd'hui s'inscrit toutefois dans
une séquence qui nous a permis de
renouveler le cadre de la politique de
solidarité internationale et j'allais
dire de reprendre la main puisque vous
vous souvenez que nous avons lourdement
pesé dans la rédaction de la loi
d'orientation et de programmation qui a
été
qui a été publié le 4 août 2021 il y a
eu après le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens de l'agence puis
très bonne chose que nous souhaitions
depuis longtemps la nomination d'une
secrétaire d'État auprès de la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
chargés du développement de la
Francophonie des partenariats
internationaux madame chrysola
zacharopulu que j'ai moi-même déjà
rencontré à sa demande et qui m'a fait
par hier de son souhait de recevoir déjà
le bureau de la commission nous
attendons également avec impatience la
prochaine mise en place de la commission
d'évaluation de l'aide au développement
parce que la loi elle date du 4 août
2021 et on a toujours entendu parler de
rien du tout et je rappelle que cette
commission d'évaluation qui est
véritablement l'apport que le Sénat
avait durement négocié j'avais pris ma
part pour essayer de trouver la solution
entre les experts et la présence des
parlementaires et je rappelle que donc
dans ce dans cette commission
d'évaluation de l'aide au développement
il y a un collège de parlementaire il me
semble important compte tenu des sommes
en question que le Parlement soit quand
même directement concerné par l'usage de
tous cet argent et donc au total il
s'agit pour nous de
nous assurer que Monsieur Riou est la
personne la mieux placée pour poursuivre
les efforts engagés par la FD afin de
mieux rendre compte de son activité
atteint des objectifs qu'on lui a fixé à
travers la loi d'orientation et de
programmation je dois dire que pour moi
c'est le principal sujet la principale
inquiétude c'est est-ce que cette loi
qui je rappelle prévoyait non seulement
un comité d'évaluation mais aussi des
orientations en pourcentage sur
l'équilibre entre l'aide au pays pauvres
et puis les et les prêts
[Musique]
multilatérales LED bilatérale etc etc
vous vous souvenez de tout cela donc
nous espérons que tout ça va être
précisé à la fois dans la présentation
quand fera monsieur Riu qui est candidat
et peut-être dans les questions que nos
deux rapporteurs puis les membres de la
commission voudront lui poser y a-t-il
des questions sur cette présentation
c'est un esquiner non c'est ça
même ce président mais je pensais parler
avant que vous commenciez à introduire à
introduire parce que on apprend que la
date du débat sur l'Ukraine au Sénat
serait plutôt fin octobre 25 octobre et
ça nous paraît en complet décalage avec
le débat qui va avoir lieu avant à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment avec les
décisions de Poutine les annonces qui
vient de faire le débat si on veut
respecter le Sénat le débat devrait
avoir lieu pratiquement à une date
similaire que celle de l'Assemblée
nationale ça c'est de la compétence de
la Conférence des Présidents moi j'étais
avisé
j'étais avisé hier et même pas du reste
par la séance mais par mon groupe qui
m'a demandé d'être le oui mais on peut
pas vouloir le respect du Sénat et puis
accepter sans faire de remarques sur des
sujets comme cela
est-ce que est-ce que le président de
groupe en saisir président du Sénat
j'avais à chaque fois besoin des
socialistes pour faire quelque chose dès
que ça peut contrarier le gouvernement
c'est quand même bizarre mais c'est le
président la commission c'est la passion
que je vous chers collègue donc c'est
normal que laisse que vous aimez mettez
un avis j'essaye d'y répondre au mieux
mais sincèrement c'est pas je peux pas
influer parce que d'abord il faut se
mettre d'accord avec le gouvernement sur
la date etc et tout moi je vois le
président midi donc je lui ferai part de
cette lieux quand l'Assemblée nationale
pas d'autres interventions avant que
nous fassions entrer l'impétrant
donc faites entrer monsieur Riou
bien prendre place face à moi
bien Monsieur le Directeur général nous
vous accueillons aujourd'hui à la suite
du Choix du Président de la République
en application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution et ce choix donc vise à
vous proposer à nouveau à proposer votre
candidature au poste de directeur
général de la FD cette audition je le
rappelle va être suivie d'un vote et
c'est cet échange entre nous doit vous
permettre à la fois de faire vos bilans
de votre dernier mandat des 6 années
passées à la tête de l'agence et de nous
faire part aussi de vos motivations pour
continuer à exercer cette fonction pour
les trois prochaines années puisque je
rappelle que c'est pour trois ans que
vous seriez nommé bien évidemment pour
nous tous il s'agit d'un moment
important vous connaissez notre
attachement à cette politique de
solidarité internationale sans laquelle
notre action extérieure qu'elle soit
diplomatique ou qu'elle soit militaire
serait bien incomplète et bien
insuffisante
nous avons constamment réaffirmé les
objectifs qui nous semblent essentiels
je les ai rappelés à plusieurs reprises
nourrir soigner éduquer ce qui n'empêche
pas bien évidemment de conjuguer ces
priorités à travers une meilleure
gouvernance des pays qui reçoivent notre
aide et de toute l'attention qu'ils
doivent
qu'ils doivent porter à la transition
énergétique et au climat nous avons
maintes fois insisté en effet sur la
nécessité d'une gouvernance efficace et
sur une évaluation transparente et
permanente de cette politique et de
l'action de son bras armé donc je vais
laisser la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
pour nous présenter votre parcours et
vous posez les premières questions après
je vous propose de faire un exposé
limaire d'une quinzaine de minutes et je
donnerai aussi la parole aux autres
collègues qui s'inscriront je rappelle
que cette audition en application de
l'article 13 est ouverte au public
ouverte à la presse elle est enregistrée
et diffusée sur le site du Sénat
Internet et
mon petit doigt me dit qu'elle est très
attendue
monsieur les rapporteurs vous avez la
parole pour la présentation
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général mes chers collègues
Monsieur le Directeur Général votre
parcours et marquer dès l'origine par
les questions de développement puisque
vous avez exercer les fonctions de chef
de la coopération monétaire et du
développement avec les pays d'Afrique
des Caraïbes et du Pacifique de 2004 à
2007 puis dessous directeur des affaires
financiers internationales et du
développement à la direction générale du
Trésor de 2010 à 2012 vous avez ensuite
dirigé le cabinet de Pierre Moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
vous êtes devenus secrétaire général
adjoint du ministère des Affaires
étrangères et du développement
international en 2014 vous avez enfin
été nommé le 2 juin 2016 directeur
général de la FD est reconduit dans
cette fonction en mai 2019 votre mandat
est arrivé à expiration juin dernier et
vous avez assuré depuis un intérim
après avoir ainsi retracé brièvement
votre parcours je voudrais plus
particulièrement vous interroger sur
trois points le premier vient tout
naturellement quels sont pour vous les
grands axes du bilan des six années
passées à la tête de l'AFD vous vous
étiez notamment engagé en 2016 ici même
à rendre lived plus grande plus agile et
plus partenariale pensez-vous avoir
atteint ces objectifs et inversement que
referiez-vous différemment en
particulier quelles leçons tirez-vous
des résultats très mitigés de nos
efforts pour mettre en place une
approche 3D au Sahel et en particulier
au Mali alors dans les 3D il y en a un
qui pour lequel vous ne pouvez pas faire
grand-chose mais un autre un peu moins
mais un pour lequel vous vous avez la
main
celui du développement pendant votre
premier mandat et le début du second
l'activité de l'agence a été marquée par
une croissance très rapide avec des
engagements passant de 9 milliards
d'euros en 2016 à plus de 14 milliards
d'euros en 2019 les pays émergents ont
été les premiers bénéficiaires de cette
croissance qui a d'abord concerné les
prêts ce qui a pu si susciter dans notre
part des interrogations le nombre
d'agents de la FD a également fortement
augmenté avec par exemple une hausse de
8,9% entre 2018 et 2019 la suite de
votre deuxième mandat a en revanche été
marquée par une baisse subite et subie
de l'activité du notamment à la crise du
covid il ne s'agit pas d'un coup d'arrêt
temporaire car le manque de solvabilité
des destinataires de l'aide c'est
aggravé notamment dans une Afrique
menacée par le sérendettement ceci a
conduit le gouvernement à vous demander
de stabiliser l'activité de l'agence à
environ 12 milliards d'euros à partir de
d'une croissance constante on passe donc
à un effort pour maintenir les acquis
mais avec une agence dimensionnée avant
la crise en termes d'effectif
ma question est la suivante pensez-vous
être le mieux placé pour piloter un tel
changement de cap êtes-vous prêt à
changer de logiciel pour passer de la
recherche permanente de nouveaux clients
entre guillemets pour les prêts de la FD
à une réorientation de vos efforts vers
les pays les plus pauvres et les projets
en don qui les concernent comme la loi
vous oblige enfin à ma connaissance vous
êtes unique candidat pour exercer cette
fonction pouvez-vous nous expliquer
quelles sont les raisons qui rendent ce
poste si peu propice à une je serais
tenté de dire à une scène concurrence
l'AFD c'est le troisième point à des
engagements très importants dans les
grands émergents environ 2 milliards par
an visant notamment à orienter le
développement de ces pays dans le sens
un sens conforme à l'accord de Paris en
or sur le C7 grands émergents nos
relations sont notarment dégradées avec
trois pays la Turquie la Chine mais
aussi le Brésil quelles sont les
conséquences de cette situation sur
l'activité de l'agence dans ces pays
comment entendez-vous les critiques qui
pointent le paradoxe qu'il y a à
financer des pays dont les autorités ont
une attitude négative voire agressive à
l'encontre de la France par ailleurs
sommes-nous réellement en mesure de
peser pour une meilleure prise en compte
des exigences environnementales par ces
pays ce qui constitue aujourd'hui la
seule raison d'être de l'action de la FD
dans ceci voilà je vous remercie
merci avant de passer la parole à
racheter mal je manque à tous mes
devoirs parce que je voudrais accueillir
notre collègue Ludovic hay qui rejoint à
nouveau notre commission au nom du RPI
et je lui souhaite une seconde bienvenue
merci à toi allez Rachid merci président
ce directeur général donc moi j'aurais
trois quatre questions pardon d'abord
rappeler aussi le cas dans lequel tout
ça s'opère puisque nous avons
effectivement adopté le 4 août 2021 loi
de programmation d'orientation de
formation chacun se rappelle ici que
c'était elle avait de programmation
collective puisque ont été déjà à la fin
qu'il fallait revenir en arrière on va
pas revenir dessus mais ce qui est
important quand même de rappeler et je
reprends là les mots de du ministre le
trian à l'époque c'était l'idée c'était
de passer d'une politique de l'outil un
outil au service de la politique et je
pense que ça qui était le plus important
dans notre discussion donc le premier
point que j'évoquerai c'est sur
[Musique]
mais l'idée c'était bien d'avoir ces
trois missions là c'est également
d'avoir un travail notamment sur la
répartition plus claire entre la
question des prêts et la question des
dons sur bien évidemment la question du
multale ou du bilatéral il y avait aussi
un centre de d'orientation prioritaire
notamment sur le climat notamment sur la
question de jeu etc etc donc la question
c'est est-ce que depuis maintenant plus
d'un an est-ce que tout cela a pu
avancer si oui quels sont les résultats
quels sont les perspectives
même question sur la question du contrat
adoptif et de moyens puisque là aussi
c'était le paradoxe de cela on nous a
été demandé je crois un mois plus tard
et il était déjà déphasé et total retard
donc la question aussi se posera mais
c'est pas votre de votre ressort mais
une loi proche de notre programmation en
tout cas sur la loi et sur le com
quelles sont aujourd'hui les avancées là
où nous en sommes les points de
difficultés éventuels les points de
révolution nécessaire voilà tout cela
nous nous importe beaucoup sur la mise
en oeuvre de ces deux éléments qui nous
semblent essentiels deuxième point on a
été nombreux à être nous sommes nombreux
à avoir été sollicités par les syndicats
puisque il y a une réforme des
personnels de la FD avec plusieurs
niveaux plusieurs étages il y avait bien
évidemment une mesure liée à un décret
mais pour autant je considère que on
peut aussi avoir du dialogue social même
si à la fin il y a un décret sous le
décret n'est qu'un outil quant au
dialogue social il nécessaire donc
pouvez-vous nous dire exactement ce
qu'il en est puisque à la lecture des
documents des syn bien c'est dialogue
social nous sommes relativement inquiets
et donc il sera intéressant de savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur la
question des statuts mais également sur
les prochaines étapes que ce soit sur
notamment les nouveaux formes de travail
dans en général votre façon de voir le
diagnostal dans l'entreprise et puis
également par rapport aux différentes
unités à l'intérieur puisque je rappelle
qu'il y a trois unités dans le groupe et
puis je sais que la question qui sera
mon point d'après sur la question du
siège importe également la question de
l'orgation donc voilà la question du
dialogue social ce qui s'est passé
comment vous entendez le poursuivre
l'améliorer le densifier parce que nous
considérons qu'il est important
qu'effectivement le dioxal soit majeur
et que des accords soient trouvés
entre la direction que vous représentez
et les relations syndicales qui sont qui
nous ont écrit je crois que chacun le
président les a reçu également je crois
que chacun pour reconnaître une cité
d'avoir des éclaircissements sur ce
point là
et le président de la commission et
parce que au dessus de toi j'oublie
toujours qui est aussi présent du Sénat
voilà donc le président du Sénégal plus
sérieusement troisième point c'est sur
la question du siège de l'AFD va se
débat je parvenir sur l'historique je
crois que je crois que c'est occupé
beaucoup d'autres commissions pendant
très longtemps mais il reste toujours la
question donc peut-être nous refaire un
point de là où nous en sommes du dossier
avec tous ces aléas que ce soit sur la
question juridique sur la question
financière sur la question calendaire et
puis je crois qu'il y avait aussi un
sujet dedans un sujet dans le sujet
puisque sauf un appart sur les 50 000
m², il y en a 10 000 qui ne seront pas
affectés ou qui ne seraient pas affectés
à la FD et il y a de ce que nous avions
entendu avec huxury sur les différentes
auditions deux positions à l'époque et
c'est intéressant qu'on est peut-être
une évolution aujourd'hui d'un côté le
pour faire simple Bercy qui disait bah
nous soit vous louez soit vous vendez
les 10000 mètres carrés en plus
donc ça veut dire des entrées d'entrée
financière One Shot ou régulièrement et
puis plutôt le cake était sur on peut
imaginer une forme de cité
du développement et on sait avec des
opérateurs qui seraient moins en
capacité de financer donc il y a une
question de de réalité financière et
puis le dernier élément pour pas être
trop long qui je crois est très
important pour nous c'est la question du
travail avec le Parlement alors c'est
vrai que
il y a aujourd'hui une ministre et
c'était une vieille demande donc c'est
une bonne chose
mais il y a effectivement les auditions
mais nous souhaitons nous savoir au-delà
de ce qui est j'ai envie de dire la base
le minimum les auditions sur les avis
etc comment pensez-vous comment
souhaitez-vous travailler avec le
Parlement et en l'espèce le Sénat dans
les prochaines dans les prochains dans
les trois prochaines années c'est à dire
que nous considérons nous que il faut
densifier pour dire reprendre
l'expression historique il faut muscler
son jeu pour que nous ayons
effectivement un travail plus régulier
pas seulement sur l'aspect budgétaire
plus ou moins 30% etc mais également sur
les questions de stratégie sur les
questions de suite grand dossiers il y a
le CA bien sûr de l'AFD mais l'océan
n'est pas le CA et l'océan ou là on
parle du Parlement et donc comment le
Parlement peut régulièrement être
associé aux éléments de stratégie aux
éléments de ciblage aux éléments de
parfois de de réadaptation de la
stratégie comme j'ai vu tout à l'heure
avec quand il y a le covid comment on
fait voilà comment on entend vous
entendez pardon avoir un travail on va
dire plus étroit plus plus concret avec
le Parlement et voilà j'en ai fini de
mes quatre questions
merci messieurs les rapporteur alors je
vous propose donc pour donner un peu de
dynamique à la séance de prendre la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes ce
qui suscitera j'imagine d'autres séries
de questions j'ai déjà une liste assez
conséquente de nos collègues qui
compléteront les questions qui ont été
posées par les rapporteurs vous avez la
parole Monsieur le Directeur Général
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame Levi's présidente
messieurs les vice-président messieurs
les messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur l'administrateur de lived
mesdames les sénatrices mais messieurs
les sénateurs je suis évidemment très
très honoré de de me présenter devant
vous ce matin j'ai eu l'occasion ces six
dernières années des d'échanger avec
nombre d'entre vous mais je suis bien
sûr à la disposition de tous les
parlementaires depuis six ans j'ai été
auditionné à plus de 5 entreprises par
vos commissions et vos rapporteurs
assemblés national et Sénat confondus je
vais effectivement
rapidement dresser un bilan de mon
travail à la tête de l'agence votre
appréciation est présenté les trois
engagements que j'aurais à coeur de
réaliser au cours des prochaines années
si vous me renouvelez votre confiance
le bilan effectivement monsieur le
rapporteur je m'y étais engagé en 2016
devant votre commission et avec votre
votre soutien constant la FD devenue
plus grande elle a été dotée de 4
milliards d'euros de fonds propres
supplémentaires elle a géré en 6 ans 11
milliards d'euros de crédits budgétaire
14 même si on prend les crédits
européens que nous allons chercher avec
force dès qu'ils sont disponibles
l'agence a pu doubler dans le cas
d'expertise France triplé même son
activité chaque année passant de 7 puis
9 puis 14 milliards d'euros de 2015 à
2019 avant effectivement de se
stabiliser à 12 milliards d'euros ce qui
n'était pas une mauvaise nouvelle à dire
vrai on en avait parlé parce que
évidemment une telle croissance suppose
ensuite de réformer et de consolider ce
qui n'est pas possible quand on pousse
l'ambition et qu'on accélère et qu'on
recrute de façon aussi massive la FD
aujourd'hui est capable accompagner 1100
projets par an dans 130 pays donc c'est
ça l'outil qui est à votre disposition
vous l'aviez aussi très fortement
souhaité c'est la lettre de la loi un
effort important a été accompli sur les
dons le portefeuille de don de l'agence
à doubler en exécution il a été porté de
6 à 12 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui en
cours de en cours de mise en œuvre c'est
le stock dont les deux tiers dans les
pays les moins avancés
et bien sûr nous concentrons notre
action au maximum
toujours d'abord en Afrique
bénéficie de la moitié des financements
de l'agence similaire d'euros à peu près
par an 60% les deux tiers quasiment dans
l'Afrique francophone et l'Afrique
bénéficie de 3/4 des dons 3/4 des
subventions ça c'est pas notre décision
d'ailleurs c'est le pilotage fixé par le
gouvernement après votre avis dans les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens cette
forte croissance nous a permis
d'être présent je crois revenu sur les
grands sujets d'avoir de l'impact
dès 2017 la FD c'est aligné sur l'accord
de Paris la première des institutions
internationales à le faire elle a
d'ailleurs tenu très scrupuleusement
l'engagement pris par la France à la
cop21 puis rehaussée d'apporter chaque
année 6 milliards d'euros de finances
climat
dans cette enceinte la France étant l'un
des seuls 7 pays à avoir tenu
l'engagement pris en 2015
nous en sommes très fiers bien sûr et
puis derrière
j'ai cherché à placer l'agence à la
pointe de l'action sur la protection de
la biodiversité intimement liée au
climat et la question des la question
des océans nous sommes aussi monsieur le
Président revenu dans les domaines
sociaux l'éducation la France et le
deuxième bailleur bilatéral dans le
domaine de l'éducation après l'Allemagne
devant les États-Unis en lien étroit
avec le multilatéral le Partenariat
mondial pour l'éducation on a aussi je
crois répondu à l'urgence covid avec
l'initiative santé en commun que vous
connaissez la sécurité alimentaire
aujourd'hui l'initiative farm l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et notre
guide la moitié de nos financements
contribue précisément à réduire les
inégalités de genre
toute cette activité est jugée bonne en
transparence désormais par des
évaluateurs extérieurs nous avons aussi
beaucoup renforcé cette commission y
était très attachée vous-même monsieur
le Président notre politique
d'évaluation des projets et nous rendons
désormais des comptes beaucoup plus
précis jusqu'à l'impact pour les
populations depuis 2016 grâce à la
France c'est 200 millions de personnes
qui ont bénéficié d'un accès aux soins
c'est 80 millions d'enfants qui ont été
scolarisés 30 millions de foyers qui ont
accédé à l'électricité 10 millions à
lots 82 millions d'hectares restaurés 6
millions d'exploitations agricoles
familiales ont été soutenus c'est ça le
bilan sur 6 ans des impacts
c'était le premier point le deuxième
point c'était mon engagement
effectivement de rendre l'agence plus
agile et plus innovante notre délai
d'instruction de signatures de versement
ce sont nettement améliorés de plus de
plus d'un trimestre s'agissant de la
signature des conventions de financement
qui déclenchent évidemment l'action des
procédures adaptées au territoire en
crise ont été mises en place dans le
Sahel évidemment d'abord nous en
reparlerons sans doute un Fonds
d'innovation pour le développement
présidé par Esther Duflot a été mise en
place nous travaillons aussi sur comment
mêler création culturelle et actions de
développement dans un fond innovant une
attention croissante et portée à
l'entrepreneuriat et au digital avec je
crois une capacité à crue à financer des
projets de petite taille
l'AFD enfin est devenu nettement plus
partenariale nous avons été à
l'initiative de l'Alliance elle qui est
forte désormais de 26 membres dont les
États-Unis d'Amérique nous sommes à
l'origine de ce qu'on appelle maintenant
les équipes Europe c'est-à-dire le
rassemblement autour de la Commission
européenne des agences nationales qui se
déploient je préside le club Heidi FC et
le mouvement finance en commun
l'international des 550 banque publique
de développement dans le monde qui est
une de ces je crois de ces nouvelles
coopérations que le Président de la
République appelait de ses vœux hier à
la tribune des Nations Unies
l'AFD c'est aussi très systématiquement
tourné vers les acteurs français
la société civile le guichet pour la
société civile est passée de 65 à 165
millions d'euros chaque année les
collectivités locales on est passé de 5
projets à 74 financés avec les avec les
collectivités je le dis ici au Sénat la
Caisse des Dépôts les établissements
publics les entreprises les
philanthropes bientôt Paris 2024 donc
nous sommes partenaires officiels parce
que le sport est un accélérateur de
développement l'audiovisuel extérieur
auquel vous êtes très attaché ici avec
plus de 50 millions d'euros de projets
en cours avec le groupe France media
monde et CFI en son sein
enfin pour le bilan j'ai veillé à ce que
cette transformation profonde soit
réalisée avec sérieux et en préservant
nos équilibres financiers et de gestion
nos risques sont maîtrisés malgré cette
grande croissance nos comptes sont tenus
nous avons dégagé l'année dernière le
résultat net le plus élevé de l'histoire
de l'agence 300 millions d'euros et
l'année en cours nous approuverons les
comptes semestrielles demain et bonne
notre cadre social oui monsieur le
rapporteur a été a été modernisé avec la
réforme du statut du du personnel j'y
reviendrai sans doute mais bien sûr
c'est gains d'efficacité qui ont été qui
ont été obtenus je plaide devant vous
pour dire que passer par l'Agence
française de développement c'est
beaucoup plus efficace et le rapport
qualité prix est bien meilleur que par
d'autres canaux souvent multilatéraux en
tout cas on a cherché à créer cet
avantage comparatif évidemment ça s'est
fait ça n'a pas été facile
donc on l'a fait dans le dialogue social
je rappelle ici que nous avons signé 11
accords collectifs les deux dernières
années et plus encore si on remonte à
2016 les instances fonctionnent
évidemment et je remercie je remercie
les tous les personnels de la FD et les
organisations syndicales et les
représentants du personnel pour cela on
a eu effectivement un débat et un
désaccord sur la réforme des statuts du
personnel qui est vous le savez un
arrêté du ministre des Finances
on a eu de longues discussions un 5 ans
de travail une trentaine de réunions
alors je n'ai pas souhaité que ce soit
négociation mais de discussion il me
semblait qu'on négociait pas un acte
réglementaire c'est le privilège du du
gouvernement et du ministre mais enfin
soyez rassurés sur le fait qu'il y a eu
beaucoup d'échanges après certaines des
cinq organisations syndicales de l'AFD
n'ont pas validé le résultat de cette
on a maintenant des discussions sur les
accords collectifs cette fois qui
découlent de ce nouveau statut j'ai bon
espoir j'ai rencontré toutes les
organisations syndicales évidemment
avant de de me présenter devant vous que
nous allons reprendre et c'est mon
engagement évidemment un dialogue social
apaisé à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
pour poursuivre les réformes cette
entreprise et ses salariés qui
respectent là aussi et je les en
remercie scrupuleusement les objectifs
du contrat d'objectif et de moyens fixés
avec l'État vous savez à plus de 90% les
indicateurs qui ont été fixés ont été
ont été atteints je signale aussi la
profonde transformation de notre corps
social la parité totale entre les femmes
et les hommes a été atteintes cet été
dans notre management et à toutes les
strates du management y compris nos
directrices et nos directeurs d'agents
que vous rencontrez très régulièrement
sur le terrain j'en suis là aussi très
fier
bon ce bilan n'est bien sûr qu'une étape
mais une base je l'espère solide sur
laquelle
construire l'étape suivante
c'est mon deuxième point pour les trois
prochaines années cette étape suivante
évidemment sa ligne est très claire
c'est vous qui l'avez fixé évidemment
dans la loi du 4 août 2021 et dans son
rapport annexé évidemment connu en
détail de notre agence cette loi qui
fonde je crois un nouveau récit beaucoup
plus partenariale une nouvelle position
qui qui que vous avez souhaité qui nous
oblige et qui fixe les priorités à
respecter il en est découlé une nouvelle
organisation gouvernementale avec à
nouveau depuis le mois de mai dernier
une secrétaire d'État chargée du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux madame
crisoula zachau et les trois ministres
qui exercent la tutelle de l'AFD
Catherine colonnat Bruno Le Maire et
Jean-François karaco près de Gérald
Darmanin dans ce cadre et en équipe
France très intégrée évidemment la
première orientation que je voudrais
vous proposer
que l'agence dans les trois prochaines
années
soit plus pertinente encore et s'adapte
très rapidement aux évolutions
géopolitiques majeures en cours
évidemment la guerre en Ukraine change
complètement le paysage par rapport à la
dernière fois que je me suis présenté
avec vous et je crois qu'il est encore
plus important dans les années qui
viennent effectivement de de raisonner
et d'agir en 3D la diplomatie bien sûr
qui nous guide la défense bien sûr mais
aussi le développement pilier à part
entière de notre politique étrangère
à dispose dispose la loi on a commencé à
le faire je
répondrai sans doute à des questions
dans le Sahel bien sûr on a compris que
les cette crise a des racines sociales
économiques très profondes et que le
changement climatique exacerbe encore
les tensions les tensions politiques et
les tensions de sécurité et que
malheureusement cette crise est de court
terme certainement et suppose une action
dans la durée et en profondeur je
propose de mobiliser également cette
capacité unique de mon point de vue que
l'Agence française de développement à
agir du côté des autres
tisser des liens avec un très grand
nombre de partenaires
de l'influence bien sûr de l'amitié
aussi je pense qu'on peut le faire
beaucoup plus efficacement dans
l'Indopacifique vous en revenez je crois
en Amérique latine très importante
autour de l'Union européenne cette
communauté politique quelle est sa
dimension de développement ce qui veut
dire bien sûr autour de la Russie dans
les Balkans sans oublier la question
chinoise structurante et bien sûr de
plus en plus difficile
pour l'Afrique qui sera toujours notre
priorité il faut lutter contre la
pauvreté d'abord et l'augmente
dramatiquement je souhaite aussi qu'on
insiste sur l'investissement dans le
secteur privé dans les entreprises et
pour la création d'emplois le défi ici
vous le savez gigantesque en 2050 un
jeune sur trois de moins de 25 ans dans
le monde sera africain chaque année
c'est 30 millions de jeunes c'est-à-dire
le Cameroun la Côte d'Ivoire Madagascar
qui arrive sur le marché du travail en
Afrique et seul 10% d'entre eux ils
trouvent un emploi formel
il faut donc passer à l'échelle dans
l'appui à l'entrepreneuriat dans le
soutien aux industries nouvelles ou bien
c'est l'instabilité politique qui
grandira avec les mouvements migratoires
aussi qui s'amplifieront à l'intérieur
de l'Afrique et au-delà un mot rapide
vous l'avez cité monsieur le rapporteur
sur les outre-mer
et l'Indo Pacifique d'ailleurs pour deux
bassins océaniques j'entends leur donner
une grande priorité compte tenu des
difficultés auxquelles ces territoires
font face mais aussi de leur
positionnement qui est absolument unique
on a bâti vous le savez une stratégie
qui s'appelle trois océans pour
travailler dans ces territoires dans cet
historique pour l'agence mais aussi avec
tous leurs voisins je pense qu'elle doit
être approfondie je pense qu'on doit
avoir de nouveaux instruments outre-mer
y compris les instruments subventions le
ministère d'ailleurs que des Outre-mer
que je remercie le fait désormais pour
que on puisse déployer toutes les
capacités de cette agence également dans
ces territoires et puis enfin sur cette
géopolitique je suis très bref et trop
schématique il faut je crois travailler
à comprendre l'articulation de plus en
plus complexe entre les fractures
géopolitiques et les questions et les
questions globales la très sévère
dégradation de l'indice de développement
humain l'année dernière pour la première
fois depuis
32 ans cet indice est en baisse dans 9
pays sur 10 dans le monde on est revenu
au niveau de 2016 en 2021 et bien sûr
si on ajoute à ça la crise climatique
qui est partout tout cela va ajouter de
très profondes vulnérabilités jusqu'au
politique évidemment lui-même et on peut
être un capteur pour vous évidemment
pour mieux comprendre ses liens entre
les deux crises à laquelle nous faisons
face la deuxième orientation que je
voudrais donner pardon j'accélère c'est
de faire de l'agence c'est un engagement
de qualité c'est de faire de l'agence
la première agence 100% objectif de
développement durable au DD
d'ici à 2025 il y a rien de théorique
dans un tel engagement ça veut dire
évidemment nourrir soigner former comme
vous le vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président ça veut dire construire des
infrastructures ça veut dire apporter de
l'eau ça veut dire gérer des déchets ça
veut dire scolariser les jeunes filles
ça veut dire renforcer les systèmes de
santé de base ça veut dire répondre à la
demande qui nous est adressée et ça vous
connaissez toutes les compétences
techniques de l'agence vous les voyez
mais ça veut dire le faire bien ça veut
dire le faire mieux ça veut dire essayer
de combiner finalement la demande et le
climat et donc d'essayer un peu
systématiquement l'agence s'y est prête
à maximiser finalement la qualité des
projets et à contribuer à la définition
de bonne politique publique dans les
pays nous travaillons d'ailleurs à ce
que la FD devienne la première
institution à se financer exclusivement
par des obligations vertes et durables
sur les marchés financiers on est à 50%
aujourd'hui essayons d'être à 100% dans
trois ans ce serait un signal je crois
très fort dans le monde financier que
c'est possible
et puis 100% des dés ça veut dire aussi
aller juste là où c'est possible aller
jusqu'au droits humains droit des
enfants même vous avez eu ce débat dans
le cadre de la loi c'est le troisième
objectif que vous nous avez fixé avec la
lutte contre la pauvreté et les biens
publics mondiaux c'est assez nouveau
pour l'agence donc nous sommes en train
de réfléchir avec votre aide ce que ça
veut dire finalement
de pousser la question des institutions
de pousser la question de la gouvernance
de pousser la question des droits
et le faire peut-être en se posant la
question d'une façon un peu renouvelée
en passant par gel gear par en bas par
les projets en démontrant finalement à
nos partenaires que donner des droits
aux femmes c'est plus de développement
on en a la preuve ils en ont la preuve
et quand c'est possible pourquoi ne pas
pousser jusqu'à chercher à changer le
cas de législatif il y a des pays où ça
sera pas possible
quand c'est possible peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on a une certaine
timidité qu'on pourrait essayer d'aller
plus loin plus fort dans ce domaine je
crois ici d'ailleurs en particulier à la
force de la diplomaties parlementaire à
votre rôle au rôle des parlements dans
ce domaine je mobiliserai la FD monsieur
le rapporteur pour vous appuyer beaucoup
plus fortement à l'avenir dans votre
action internationale c'est si vous le
souhaitez évidemment oui vous
représentants au conseil
d'administration autour de vos
rapporteurs sur les crédits de l'aide de
développement les quatre membres je
crois de la future Commission
d'évaluation les administrateurs
d'expertise France on a vous tous on a
de multiples liens et c'est important de
recueillir vos attentes
des travaux parlementaires avec nos
équipes sur les stratégies en
particulier la stratégie globale ou
certaines stratégies géographiques
pourraient nous guider des visites de
terrain conjointe sont extrêmement
précieuses pour moi
la conclusion d'un partenariat hier avec
l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
Francophonie va également dans le même
sens votre disposition vraiment pour
poursuivre cet échange
enfin toute dernière orientation je
souhaite d'ici à 2025 déployer
pleinement le groupe AFD composé de
l'AFD de Proparco et d'expertise France
vous l'avez souhaité également dans la
loi forme maintenant de ces 3500
collaborateurs je pense qu'il faut
cesser de voir la FD d'ailleurs
uniquement comme une institution
financière et mesurer son succès au sol
volume finalement ou grand chiffre pour
regarder les choses de façon beaucoup
plus précise et dans notre capacité à
combiner des interventions financières
bien sûr et des
interventions je dirais non financières
plus humaine de formations de
renforcement de capacité c'est ce que le
renfort d'expertise France nous apporte
on va travailler beaucoup sur le sujet
de la formation vous savez on a un
campus à Marseille depuis très longtemps
on va on va y mettre aussi le budget de
formation de l'AFD l'idée étant de faire
un ensemble qui permettent de former
ensemble nos salariés nos clients nos
partenaires tous ceux y compris au sein
de l'État qui veulent reconstituer ou
constituer parce que je ne sais pas si
elle a jamais vraiment existé une
filière des métiers de développement
toujours dans cette même perspective et
à la suite de la loi on veut aussi
renforcer beaucoup dans les prochaines
années notre capacité à mobiliser les
autres acteurs oui monsieur le
rapporteur le notre déménagement garde
Austerlitz probablement en 2026
maintenant on a un peu de temps pourrait
servir aussi outre nos propres besoins
optimiser à mobiliser accueillir
d'autres acteurs y compris des
organisations internationales qui
voudraient collaborer avec nous je vous
rassure quand bien même nous n'y
arriverons que partiellement cet
investissement immobilier on s'en est
expliqué reste évidemment une façon
d'optimiser considérablement nos coûts
de gestion est un très bon
investissement patrimonial vous
connaissez l'évolution du marché de
l'immobilier de bureau en ce moment à la
suite avec le télétravail à la suite de
la de la crise covid mais il y a ce
supplément qu'on voudrait bâtir
évidemment avec le ministère avec vous
tous qui peuvent attirer à Paris des
partenaires enfin dernier point certains
je sais que vous y êtes très attachés je
pense qu'il faut une politique de
communication de la sur la politique de
développement beaucoup plus forte fixé
évidemment par l'État mais où la FD
pourrait jouer un rôle beaucoup plus
fort en amenant le plus possible de
preuves concrètes finalement que
l'engagement de la France est positif
apporte du bien-être en visant peut-être
on l'a fait beaucoup dans notre propre
pays les 15-25 ans on a développé un
certain nombre d'actions il faudrait les
passer à l'échelle à un moment où vous
le savez la diffusion de messages
anti-français et l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens face aux dérèglement
internationaux géopolitique et
climatiques et très fortement croissante
alors pour être travaillé avec le monde
du volontariat on peut travailler plus
encore avec la société civile avec les
collectivités locales avec vous donc
voilà monsieur le Président les axes
possibles d'un mandat que je sollicite
derrière la loi pour les trois
prochaines années je crois avoir titre
personnel l'expérience et désormais les
amitiés partout dans le monde pour
servir utilement la politique de
développement et achevée finalement
cette grande transformation de la FD
pour donner à la France un outil
puissant agile et efficace je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général pour
cette présentation à la fois du bilan et
des du projet que vous souhaitez porter
et tout de suite donc je vais donner la
parole aux autres membres de la
commission en leur demandant compte tenu
du nombre d'intervenants et du temps que
je souhaite vous laisser pour répondre à
comprimer votre pensée Joël guerriot
merci Président Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous présidez l'international
développement de finance Club qui
regroupe 24 agences de développement à
travers le monde votre club représente
le plus grand fournisseur de finances
publiques
et climatique
la coque 21 a donné lieu à l'accord de
Paris en 2015
cet accord nous engage à sortir au plus
vite des énergies fossiles pour
atteindre la neutralité climatique en
2050 et la seule solution crédible c'est
de substituer les sources d'énergie
fossile par de l'électricité des
carbonées or la crise actuelle montre à
quel point il y a urgence alors ma
question c'est pouvez-vous nous dire si
au cours des dernières années il y a eu
des avancées significatives avec le
soutien donc des banques de
développement public dont vous avez la
présidence sur le plan mondial merci
merci Joël marie-arlet Carlotti
oui monsieur Riou je voulais vous dire
que les socialistes sont très attachés à
l'Agence française du développement
parce que lorsque Lionel Jospin a
transformé la caisse française de
développement en agence il avait
vraiment pour objectif d'abord de mettre
fin à la France Afrique et à ses dérives
mais aussi de trouver un outil pour
financer le développement donc du coup
au début on souhaite un outil pour
financer le développement et chemin
faisant on voudrait pas se retrouver
avec une banque donc je reprends ce
qu'on dit mais qu'aux rapporteur parce
qu'ils sont très attachés à ça dans
cette logique vous le savez la loi du 4
août 21 elle soit souhaitée favoriser la
logique des dons ça a été très insistant
là-dessus alors oui vous avez répondu
bien sûr le montant des dons en
exécution a augmenté de 2017 à 2022 mais
la part des subventions dans la
ventilation totale de la FD reste très
faible et aussi en faible croissance et
d'ailleurs en valeur absolue les prix
ont davantage augmenté que les dons donc
je reviens sur les positions de mes
corps rapporteurs là dessus la deuxième
question c'est l'aide qui transite par
les organisations de la société civile
elle devrait doubler donc atteindre
d'ici la fin de l'année 2022 620
millions je crois est-ce que ce montant
va être atteint sachant que pour nous
socialiste vous savez qu'on avait dans
tête et on continuera à se battre
là-dessus pour obtenir le 1 milliard
vous avez aussi évoqué mais vous le
savez 1% seulement de l'aide mondial
transite par les organes fait les
organisations féministes alors que
franchement les femmes partout dans tous
les pays en développement jeun rôle
fondamental vous avez évoqué ça tout à
l'heure vous avez déploré dans une des
interviews que j'ai entendu et tout à
l'heure vous avez dit la moitié où j'ai
pas bien compris la moitié de notre
budget y est consacré donc voilà
pouvez-vous développer ça parce que pour
nous c'est fondamental une autre
question vous avez beaucoup développé
dans les interventions que j'ai entendu
et là aussi maintenant l'axe
développement durable or effectivement
vous le savez aussi un dernier rapport
du pneu a montré le recul au niveau
mondial de tout ce qui est besoin
essentiel santé rééducation
traitement des enfants etc des besoins
vitaux je sais que les deux sont
conciliables mais je voudrais quand même
que vous appuyez là-dessus parce que
nous dans l'article 10 de la loi on a
demandé à l'agence de financer en
priorité les services essentiels dans
les PMA et dans les 19 pays prioritaires
dans lequel effectivement il y a
essentiellement l'Afrique deux dernières
remarques pour reprendre les deux
remarques qui ont déjà été évoquées par
les deux corps rapporteurs mais je veux
insister là-dessus la première c'est
celle qu'à évoquer luxori c'est la
stratégie 3D qui a été mise de mon point
de vue en échec au Sahel alors comment
allez-vous dans le nouveau contexte
continuer à travailler dans cette région
un nouveau contexte où il y a plus
barkhane et où la France est pas
forcément toujours la bienvenue enfin je
finis par la remarque de rachité mâle je
crois que vous avez personnellement
puisque c'est de ça dont il s'agit un
bilan plutôt positif sur le plan
économique Metz en termes sociales il me
semble que votre bilan est plus mitigé
nous constatons et Rachid l'a dit une
dégradation du climat social au sein de
la FD avec une réelle perte de sens de
la part des salariés alors vous avez
répondu en partie mais vous avez répondu
cadre social modernisé alors que Rachid
vous interrogez sur le dialogue social
et le rôle des partenaires sociaux voilà
mes questions monsieur Riou
merci merci Marie-Arlette François
Patriat Président je souhaiterais bref
d'abord l'AFD elle est connue des
parlementaires elle est connue pour
responsable politique mais est-elle
vraiment connue des Français est-ce que
les Français aujourd'hui connaissent
bien l'action que comme la FD je pense
qu'il y aurait intérêt aujourd'hui moi
les gens m'interrogent quand je leur dis
qu'on va rencontrer aujourd'hui ils me
disent mais c'est qui c'est quoi là je
crois qu'il y a besoin aujourd'hui que
la FD soit mieux connu des Français ça
permettrait de débloquer beaucoup
d'autres sujets par ailleurs la question
vous l'avez évoquée serait très brève et
vous l'avez évoqué un peu de votre
préambule c'est la guerre en Ukraine
amplifié la crise climatique et la crise
la crise alimentaire avec un contexte de
sécheresse généralisée avec des pays de
très fort dépendances notamment
l'Afrique pour l'import de matière
première agricoles on voit même que les
accords signés par les Russes
aujourd'hui
portent sur ce sujet en particulier un
exemple l'ONU nous a l'air depuis 15
jours que l'on Somalie la famine
pourrait déboîter pendant 15 jours alors
ma question est la suivante est-ce que
l'AFD vous l'avez évoqué prend bien ses
responsabilités dans cette situation et
comment votre institution
va-t-elle s'organiser pour que pour
répondre à cette crise qui a été qui a
été amplifiée par la guerre en Ukraine
merci président
Jacques
merci monsieur le Président sur le
directeur général
la crise covid a-t-elle permis une
meilleure coopération avec des autres
pays organisent d'être publiques au
développement est-ce que des événements
comme finances en commun salués par le
Président de la République lors de son
discours ambassadeurs permettent de
construire une action coordonnée et mon
autre question rejoint celle de François
Patriat et je m'appuie sur ceci l'ONG
publiche radio fun analyse la
transparence des principales agences de
développement dans le monde et cette
année elle vous classe en 28 de position
sur 50
derrière le ministère fédéral allemand
charge de la coopération économique et
du développement mais aussi l'équivalent
britannique bien que l'ONG note des
progrès certains de l'AFD depuis 2013
qu'elle puisse étudier vous afin
d'améliorer la transparence de vos
actions à travers le monde
merci Jacques Alain jouant
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
suis dans une position un peu
particulière puisque je représente le
Sénat au conseil d'administration de la
FD donc je veux pas dire je suis juge et
parti mais un peu puisque je suis amené
à émettre des votes sur les résolutions
qui nous sont proposés par
par le directeur général de l'AFB de
l'AFD le président j'aurais juste porté
si vous voulez quelques un témoignages
en quelques points d'abord sur la
croissance de l'AFD je voudrais rappeler
que c'est dans les années 2010
2010 2012 que le gouvernement a demandé
à la FD de devenir beaucoup plus
importante et d'avoir un rayonnement
beaucoup plus important si possible
mondial donc c'est l'agence à exécuté
cette demande du gouvernement de
l'époque je le rappelle
deuxième élément
l'agence
doit faire face
des allers-retours qui sont liées
souvent aux décisions politiques je vais
prendre un exemple
en Afghanistan les coopérants français
ont fait un travail exceptionnel avec
des résultats exceptionnels que je suis
allé moi-même constaté sur place y
compris pour redonner une place aux
femmes dans la société dans le travail
et du jour au lendemain la décision
politique a été de se retirer de
l'Afghanistan que fait l'agence derrière
et bien obligé de gérer les conséquences
de ces décisions politiques le deuxième
exemple que je voudrais prendre puis
enfin une conviction qui est la mienne
je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposer la
politique des dons la politique des
prêts parce que au fond ce ne sont que
des moyens
l'objectif c'est quoi l'objectif c'est
la lutte contre la pauvreté comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour lutter contre la
pauvreté c'est ça l'objectif suprême de
l'agence et des autres et des autres
agences et je pense que dans certains
cas le don est indispensable mais il l'a
vite ses limites compte tenu la
situation financière de la France et
dans d'autres cas c'est le prêt qui
atteint l'objectif de la réduction de la
pauvreté et j'ai pu aussi le constater
sur place le meilleur le meilleur
solution pour faire reculer la pauvreté
et faire arriver le progrès social c'est
quand même le développement économique
on a pu constater dans de nombreuses
régions où l'agent s'est intervenue que
là où nous avons financé des créations
d'entreprise là où nous avons financé de
la formation là où nous avons financé la
création d'emplois aussitôt aussitôt les
problèmes sociaux reculent
il y a moins de problèmes de santé les
petites filles sont scolarisées je veux
pas être trop long parce que les femmes
travaillent
on apporte cette ruche enfin on a cette
recherche permanente du progrès social
et finalement on l'atteint par ce
développement économique donc je pense
qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de
d'opposition à faire entre les dons et
les prêts et je pense que les ratios les
pourcentages sur les progressions des
uns des autres pour moi ça ne ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens au fond qu'est-ce qui
compte c'est de regarder dans les pays
où nous intervenons si on arrive à
contribuer au recul de la pauvreté et
donc c'est ça les objectifs principaux
alors j'ai pas été le seul ici dans
cette assemblée à m'occuper de ces de
ces sujets
en passant au gouvernement mais
là je vais simplement témoigner que que
l'agence est en permanence en permanence
en permanence pardon obligé de de de
changer de de s'adapter
aux décisions politiques enfin
je veux dire que l'agence même si elle a
ce rôle social évidemment très important
est aussi une entreprise
et qu'elle ne peut continuer son rôle
social que si elle est en bonne santé
parce que aujourd'hui personne ne parle
de la santé financière de l'agence mais
si l'agence d'un pas une bonne santé
elle ne peut pas continuer son action
pour faire reculer la pauvreté alors je
vais pas donner un blanc sain au
directeur général sortant parce que je
suis pas son avocat il en a pas besoin
je veux juste porter se porter ce
témoignage de la complexité de et de cet
objectif vraiment
primordial qui est le nôtre du recul de
la pauvreté dans un monde
particulièrement compliqué il suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe aux Nations
Unies et aux différents rapports de
force qui sont en train d'évoluer
entre notamment les États démocratiques
et puis ceux que l'on appelle
les États autoritaires et on voit bien
que on voit bien que l'intervention de
l'agence avec des contraintes et des
critères
de gouvernance notamment sont
particulièrement difficiles donc il faut
pas confondre les relations avec les
États et puis les relations avec les
peuples dans les pays où justement il y
a de grandes souffrances et pour
lesquelles nous devons intervenir voilà
monsieur le Président pardon d'avoir été
juste un peu long mais étant
administrateur de la FFD je voulais vous
apporter ce témoignage puisque mais fait
l'honneur de proposer au président du
Sénat d'être votre votre
représentant et je dirais que s'agissant
de cette évolution grand développement
énormément je suis chef d'entreprise à
la base quand vous avez des problèmes à
régler qui sont liés
un énorme très rapide développement
d'une entreprise bien sûr il y a des
problèmes mais c'est quand même plus
facile de régler ses problèmes là que
lorsqu'on est dans une entreprise qui
est en décrépitude et qui se rapproche
du des grandes difficultés donc il y a
des problèmes mais des problèmes qui
sont liés à la croissance qui sont liés
à l'emploi moi je voudrais bien qu'en
France on est que des problèmes qui
soient liés à l'augmentation de notre
activité économique et tout ce qui va
avec donc évidemment il y a tout ça et
puis maintenant il y a une stabilisation
sur les 12 milliards et donc
effectivement
est-ce que le directeur général sortant
est le mieux placé pour
continuer cette activité et et assuré
cette cette seuil la gestion d'un
nouveau seuil qui sera sans doute
beaucoup plus permanent j'ai tendance à
penser que son expérience sa
disponibilité
et puis maintenant c'est un très grandes
connaissance de l'agence le fait d'avoir
géré les deux premières phases et
peut-être un atout pour pour l'agence et
je lui ai déjà demandé sur la question
de du problème social à l'intérieur de
l'Agence je l'ai dit d'ailleurs au
Conseil administration qui me paraissait
très très important d'avoir une
attention
particulière dans cette période pour
pour le personnel de l'agence parce que
c'est la coopération le développement
c'est un état d'esprit et l'état
d'esprit il passe je pense par une
excellente ambiance à l'intérieur de
l'Agence merci monsieur le Président
merci Alain je rappelle que pour ceux
qui nous suivent à l'injoyandet était
secrétaire d'État à la coopération
maintenant donc Nicole Duranton
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général l'État a procédé à
plusieurs opérations de renforcement des
fonds propres de la FD depuis 2016
pourquoi ces renforcements ont-ils été
nécessaires et savez-vous d'ores et déjà
quels seront les besoins éventuels de
l'agence après 2023 je vous remercie
merci Nicole Pierre Laurent
oui bonjour Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous connaissez l'attachement de
mon groupe à la question de à l'aide
publique au développement donc je pense
que la décision que nous allons prendre
par notre vote est importante
juste une remarque qui ne vous concerne
pas personnellement mais peut-être je
pense qu'il aurait été judicieux que
qu'on procède à cette à ce vote et à
cette nomination après avoir entendu la
nouvelle secrétaire d'État
charger de la coopération parce que
quand même on est dans un
et peut-être aussi le Président il a
fait allusion
qu'on est des nouvelles notamment de la
commission d'évaluation qui a été
décidée par la loi ce que tout ça relève
d'un pilotage politique
nationale
donc là on vous on va voter pour vous
désigner ou vous donner un nouveau
mandat il faudrait que ça s'inscrive
dans une cohérence politique de l'action
de la France mais là c'est pas une
remarque qui vous concerne directement
c'est une remarque
une remarque politique plus générale je
le dis d'autant plus que je pense que
les bons vous avez mentionné et c'est
très vrai nous ont félicitons
l'augmentation des
budgets de l'agence
on est quand même très loin il faut le
dire d'avoir réglé la visée de notre
programmation budgétaire c'était l'objet
du débat
on a toujours aucune garantie que nous
allons vers une augmentation régulière
encore moins vers l'objectif des 0,7
or tout ce que vous dites par exemple le
chiffre que vous avez cité sur la
question de l'emploi en Afrique montre
que
les enjeux de développement sont tout à
fait considérables donc je suis pas sûr
qu'on soit tout à fait à la hauteur
quand on tout le monde est
tout à fait d'accord pour que enfin pas
mon groupe mais
l'objectif des deux pour cent de PIB
pour les dépenses militaires ne font
aucun débat mais je constate que
l'objectif des 0,7% pour le
développement continue d'en faire
beaucoup je suis pas sûr qu'on soit
vraiment sur la bonne voie
en la matière si on veut à assurer dans
la durée la sécurité humaine globale qui
passe par les enjeux d'alimentation
d'énergie de climat de la promotion des
droits des femmes enfin toute une série
de questions vous avez citées de ce
point de vue vous avez évoqué à nouveau
moi j'ai une question sur
les le concept 3D
d'abord il n'a pas donné des résultats
excellents au Mali c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire mais la question c'est pas
seulement que il y ait le développement
dans les 3D c'est de savoir si nos
objectifs de développement sont
assujettis à d'autres objectifs et des
objectifs d'influence et des objectifs
militaires je pense que la politique de
développement de la France a vocation à
être présente dans le monde entier
j'espère que les interventions
militaires de la France n'ont pas
vocation à ce à se développer dans le
monde entier
donc je pense que
on est en train de développer un lien
qui peut être très problématique
d'ailleurs juste à sujet j'ai une
question parce que vous avez
évoquer la coopération décentralisée
comme un acte de soutien j'ai organisé
début juillet ici en coloc sur la
question de la coopération des
centralisée avec le Mali qui est
évidemment mise très en difficulté par
la situation donc là-dessus j'avais une
question précise est-ce que la FD est
prête à appuyer la poursuite de projets
de coopération des centralisée au Mali
dans la situation actuelle c'est une
demande très générale de ceux qui sont
engagés dans cette coopération
et vous savez que la situation politique
et militaire a fait peser un très lourd
danger sur la poursuite de ces projets
qui sont pour beaucoup à l'arrêt alors
que pour la population ça a des
conséquences absolument
dramatiques
donc j'avais une question précise
là-dessus
une autre remarque que je voulais faire
mais ça rejoint ce qui était dit une
préoccupation ou une incompréhension
vous en avez vous l'avez évoqué sur la
situation sociale de la FD on a tous
effectivement été très sollicité par
l'organisation syndicale c'est très
problématique parce que évidemment dans
une agence dont le personnel en plus est
un personnel très qualifié dans
l'ensemble
l'engagement humain des personnels
évidemment est un des éléments
déterminants de le de la réussite du
travail de l'agent donc est-ce que cette
situation va réellement changer
l'origine du problème ne vous appartient
pas forcément vous l'avez signalé c'est
la volonté de moi j'appelle ça casser le
statut comme on l'a fait dans d'autres
secteurs publics c'était pas forcément
une très bonne idée c'est le moment
qu'on puisse dire mais
on aura besoin des personnels de
l'agence pour mener à bien les
politiques donc qu'est-ce que cette
situation va
changer c'est aussi une une de mes
questions et dernière remarque je
m'excuse si on peut long c'est comment
vous concevez moi je considère que la
politique de développement devrait avoir
un objectif prioritaire au-delà de plus
les objectifs ciblés sectorielles qu'on
a qui est de favoriser le développement
endogènes des pays que nous aidons parce
que il faut
l'objectif de l'aide publique au
développement c'est que les pays
puissent un jour si possible sans passer
au-delà de la nécessaire coopération
donc comment est-ce que vous envisagez
de faire évoluer le ciblage des projets
de la FD pour prioriser des projets qui
servent le développement indogène et les
infrastructures endogènes des pays des
pays concernés je pense que si nous ne
prenons pas ce Tournon
nous raterons l'objectif de l'APD et de
ce point de vue
j'ai dit que les questions n'étaient pas
personnelles mais plus politiques mais
ma dernière question puisqu'on va être
vous l'homme de ce tournant nécessaire
c'est la question que je vous pose
la question qui tue merci Pierre Olivier
Cadic
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
Monsieur le Directeur Général vous avez
évoqué votre objectif de respecter les
droits humains en mentionnant l'angle
des institutions de la gouvernance et
d'après les observateurs de terrain des
interrogations s'expriment lorsque des
entreprises chinoises mettent en œuvre
des projets financés par la FD en
Afrique comment garantissez-vous que ces
entreprises respectent justement les
droits humains confirment conformément à
nos critères est-ce que votre objectif
de respect des droits humains prévoit
une évolution de vos procédures
d'attribution de financement lorsque
certaines types d'entreprises utilisent
justement des méthodes qui ne sont pas
reconnues par nos standards un de mes
amendements adopté lors du vote de la
loi sur l'aide publique au développement
l'an dernier porté sur les tpeme
françaises à l'étranger la loi reconnaît
désormais le rôle actif des
entrepreneurs français à l'étranger dans
l'aide publique au développement cela
doit permettre au TPE PME de droit local
détenus par des entrepreneurs français à
l'étranger et les filiales des TPE
françaises à l'étranger de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un accès facilité au crédit
par le biais de garantie offert par
lived alors qu'elles en étaient
auparavant souvent écartés comment
envisager vous de répondre à cette
attente exprimée dans la loi pouvez-vous
vous engager à mettre en place un
indicateur qui nous permettrait de
suivre chaque année les progrès
consacrés au financement de nos PME
engagés dans l'effort de développement
je vous remercie merci Olivier enfin
pour finir Joëlle gariomelham
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général beaucoup
de questions ont été posées par mes
collègues alors moi je voudrais vous
exprimer des remerciements remerciements
parce que cette agence française de
développement est une fierté pour la
France je trouve que vous l'avez
conduite remarquablement je tiens à le
dire et je voudrais aussi saluer votre
engagement personnel sur un certain
nombre de dossiers je pense en
particulier
aux entrepreneurs français les petits
entrepreneurs français que vous avez
aidé pendant la crise du covid et vous
vous souvenez que ce n'était pas gagné
que nous avons beaucoup argumenté je
vous en avez beaucoup parlé je voudrais
vous remercier aussi pour l'aide
publique au développement et le soutien
dont vous nous avez parlé vous nous avez
annoncé ces 50 millions d'euros là
encore ce n'était pas gagné nous nous
sommes battus avec la Commission et en
tant que rapporteur sur ce budget
vraiment je vous en suis très
reconnaissante parce que c'était
absolument essentiel sur les droits des
femmes et des enfants aussi des dossiers
qui nous sont chers là aussi et je
voudrais mentionner parce que la
question vous avez été posée tout à
l'heure par Rachid des balles la
question des liens avec le Parlement
vous avez initié un processus qui me
paraît très intéressant qui est
l'accompagnement par des parlementaires
de certaines missions à l'étranger nous
avons été quelques-uns à le faire et je
trouve que c'est une initiative tout à
fait remarquable j'ai eu le privilège de
pouvoir vous accompagner en Moldavie
pays menacé actuellement du fait de la
crise en Ukraine où vous avez apporté en
soutien aux associations humanitaires
vous avez apporté un soutien aux petits
entrepreneurs cette mission bon je vais
faire Cora eu un impact extraordinaire
et je pense vraiment que c'est un
privilège pour les parlementaires de
vous accompagner je pense aussi que
c'est positif pour de montrer le soutien
du Parlement c'est vraiment un processus
gagnant-gagnant donc je voudrais vous
encourager à continuer dans cette voie
si vous êtes bien sûr
réélu ce que j'espère bien évidemment
merci alors en fait nous avions aussi
oublié Catherine Dumas à qui je donne la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général je
voudrais revenir vous avez dans votre
exposé parler de d'une agence plus
pertinente quant à ses choix
d'intervention et on voit bien toutes
les interventions l'ont montré que il y
avait une évolution de l'action du
groupe AFD je voudrais revenir sur ce
qu'a dit le rapporteurux sorry dans son
intervention en parlant de la Chine
depuis 2004 la FD intervient dans le
cadre d'un partenariat avec les
autorités chinoises pour développer des
actions de coopération en matière de
développement durable et aussi de lutte
contre le changement climatique on sait
que un projet sont financés par la FD
donc je voudrais que vous nous donniez
quelques précisions pourquoi la Chine
n'a-t-elle pas les moyens de financer
elle-même ce type de projet et puis
surtout justement est-ce que c'est
compatible avec les nouveaux objectifs
que vous vous fixez voilà très bonne
série de questions
auxquelles il vous appartient de
répondre vous avez la parole Monsieur le
Directeur Général
merci monsieur le Président et merci
merci à vous toutes et tous pour pour
ces questions là je vais les regrouper
d'abord peut-être en quatre blocs puis
je si j'ai le temps je passerai
dans mes notes pour n'oublier n'oubliez
personne dans l'espoir de pouvoir
poursuivre cette discussion évidemment
au-delà de cette audition le premier
point c'est
vous l'avez dit le les institutions de
développement sont prises depuis 2015
dans une très forte tension
qui est évidemment la volonté le souhait
la nécessité de d'allouer le maximum de
ressources possibles
pour financer ce que personne ne finance
au fond et donc pour aller dans les
territoires les plus reculés auprès des
populations les plus défavorisées et
pour lutter contre la pauvreté donc
n'ayez aucun doute sur le fait que c'est
la volonté de cette agence
et on est très heureux d'être revenu
dans le Sahel j'en dirais un mot dont on
avait quand même un peu disparu trop
longtemps faute de moyens en subvention
puisque dans un certain nombre de ces
territoires ou dans les domaines sociaux
il faut des dons évidemment il en faut
plus je dirais l'agence est prête en
gérer toujours plus c'est la décision
que vous prenez chaque année dans les
lois de finances donc il faut allouer le
maximum pour faire ça évidemment mais et
vous l'avez écrit dans les objectifs de
la politique de développement dans la
loi nous sommes aussi depuis 2015 avec
l'accord de Paris et les objectifs de
développement durable finalement chargé
d'une autre mission qui est d'essayer de
mobiliser le maximum d'acteurs pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
les deux missions étant liées d'ailleurs
et le faire avec évidemment notre nos
valeurs et avec une qualité qui inclut
aussi le respect des droits humains
c'est les trois objectifs que vous avez
fixés dans la loi et donc et donc la
difficulté du travail de cet c'est
d'arriver à
concilier et elle a évidemment besoin
d'une clarification politique c'est ce
que vous faites et c'est ce que fait le
contrat d'objectif et de moyens sur où
est-ce qu'on met ou est-ce qu'on mène
aux forces et tant entendu je crois
qu'il faut faire les trois et que c'est
la mission que vous nous avez confié
alors
plus de dons bien sûr
on est gré pour maintenant gérer des
volumes significatifs de dons y compris
dans des dans des situations très
difficiles le faire avec la coopération
décentralisée bien sûr Monsieur Laurent
au Mali on a effectivement dans la
difficulté où nous sommes on a arrêté
les financements avec le gouvernement
malien les autorités maliennes disons on
cherche évidemment
c'est le mandat en tout cas politique
qui est le nôtre à maintenir des actions
auprès de la société civile ou des
collectivités locales de la population
malienne
bien sûr à la réserve de la sécurité
pour nos collègues et pour vos les
agents des collectivités locales qui
s'engagent les élus qui s'engagent dans
la coopération décentralisée on est tout
à fait désireux de poursuivre et
d'amplifier cette action on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup augmenté on est à 13 millions
d'euros maintenant sur la coopération
décentralisée en lien avec le ministère
on cherche des projets en fait on en
cherche plus papa que dans le Sahel bien
sûr et je vous ai donné les chiffres sur
l'augmentation très rapide des projets
accompagnés
le climat le développement durable
évidemment on peut pas le faire tout
seul on n'est pas avec 12 milliards
d'euros à l'échelle de ce problème et
donc là je réponds à la question du
sénateur guerriot on essaie de le faire
avec les autres institutions financières
publiques les autres banques publiques
de développement et ça donc l'une des
façons de le faire c'est ce club idfive
28 même maintenant avec banque publique
puissante un peu partout dans le monde
beaucoup dans les pays émergents ou
c'est là quand même que va se jouer la
bataille de la transition énergétique de
l'arrêt du charbon des énergies
renouvelables de la baisse des émissions
et on a lancé au-delà même de ce club
idfc qui fait quand même chaque année
plus de 200 milliards de dollars
d'investissement dans le climat on a
fait on a fait 1000 milliards de dollars
avec tous nos collègues depuis l'accord
de Paris bon la FDC 6 milliards par an
mais voyez on a une discussion avec des
institutions financières nationales dans
les pays qui sont devenus nos amis très
puissantes et je crois à l'échelle des
problèmes où nous sommes s'ils arrivent
bien sûr à mobiliser aussi des flux
financiers privés et elle est tournée
dans la bonne direction ça c'est le
travail donc dans cette autre enceinte
qui s'appelle finance en commun qui est
là non pas 28 mais l'invitation faite à
toutes les caisses des dépôts finalement
du monde de travailler sur les bonnes
méthodologies d'orienter leurs
investissements le plus rapidement
possible
vers le développement durable et c'est
moi je l'ai découvert depuis six ans
c'est vraiment un groupe une enceinte où
j'ai jamais rencontré quelqu'un avec qui
j'étais pas d'accord pour être tout à
fait clair donc il y a là quelque chose
d'assez spécial
et la FDV voilà encore une fois faire le
plus possible avec les moyens que vous
donnez là où c'est là où il y a personne
et faire le plus possible à la limite
avec le moins de moyens possible vous
voyez en démultipliant avec les autres
institutions financières publics mais on
a on a bien sûr cette tension qu'il faut
gérer sur lequel on a besoin
d'orientation politique vous en avez une
donnée une très claire sur les sujets
plus géopolitique bon
le 3D pour moi
c'est le retour de la politique de
développement c'est le mot qu'on a
trouvé je me souviens en 2016 discuter
avec certains amis collègues leur dire
3D
et il me répondait mais je ne comprends
pas ce que tu dis il y en a que deux
et on a la politique de développement a
peut-être un moment été considéré
uniquement comme l'instrument d'autres
politiques vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Laurent moi je pense et c'est vous
l'avez fait avec tellement de force dans
une loi que c'est une politique publique
dont l'agence et l'opérateur tout
simplement après ça veut pas dire de mon
point de vue qu'elle ne doit pas
s'articuler avec les autres politiques
publiques dès lors que ces moyens ont
été restaurés et que ça fonctionne et
claire pour tout le monde donc c'est ça
pour moi le sens de 3D et elle n'est pas
subordonnée en fait d'autres politiques
publiques elle est un pilier de notre
action internationale à combiner
évidemment par les autorités politiques
à pondérer avec nos autres capacités
finalement visage à l'international
c'est ça dans la plupart des pays du
monde d'ailleurs et c'est de nouveau je
dirais fortement le cas en France
évidemment le directeur général de l'AFD
en est particulièrement
heureux et je pense que dans le Sahel
c'est très important d'avoir le
troisième d parce que sinon on fait de
mauvaises analyses on a peut-être cru
qu'on allait stabiliser rétablir la
situation dans le Sahel de façon rapide
qu'on allait aussi faire du
développement peut-être de façon un peu
mécanique on pacifié puis on développait
nous on s'est prêté à ce jeu
effectivement ça nous a d'ailleurs et je
remercie le ministère de la Défense qui
a beaucoup expliqué les limites de son
action et la nécessité de renforcer les
moyens du développement on est passé à
l'évidence à une autre étape maintenant
bien sûr qui range je crois encore plus
nécessaire cette action de long terme
cette action sur les les causes sociales
les causes économiques les causes
climatiques de ces crises et je le dis
évidemment avec le plus de modestie
possible de retour dans sa haine
l'agence est de retour elle fait
beaucoup de choses avec beaucoup de
partenaires mais dans une situation qui
qui est très dégradée bien sûr et et
comme le militaire n'était pas la seule
solution le développement ne l'est pas
non plus je pense c'est d'autres c'est
de la combinaison et du soutien et de
l'attention qu'on apporte à ces pays à
ces populations que j'espère
un avenir meilleur ce dégagera donc ça
c'est une façon de répondre aussi à la
priorité des pays pauvres on a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup augmenté dans les
pays les moins avancés nos financements
on a beaucoup augmenté aussi de près de
80% dans les pays prioritaires de l'être
française depuis 2016 c'est sans doute
pas assez encore je suis tout à fait
prêt à le dire et je voudrais faire plus
mais la tendance je dirais est
positive
les autres questions que vous m'avez
posé porte plus sur des pays plus
développés disons plus avancé l'Ukraine
monsieur Patriat bien sûr donc l'AFD
n'a pas de mandat à ce jour en Ukraine
nous y sommes intervenus en urgence un
peu pour faire un premier prêt de
soutien budgétaire sur les activités
civiles sur les services de base de 300
millions d'euros il y a quelques
semaines peut-être nous serons à nouveau
appelé à le faire
expertise France désormais dans le
groupe a un peu d'action notamment sur
la question des crimes de guerre sur le
renforcement de la justice et je pense
être utile trop parcours avec quelques
investissements ça ne fait pas un mandat
aujourd'hui
ukrainien je dirais
c'est une question je pense à présent
que nous sommes en Moldavie en Géorgie
dans le Caucase dans les Balkans est-ce
que la somme de ces interventions fait
une stratégie un objet stratégique que
je dis j'ai dit dans mon propos
liminaire
autour de l'Union européenne on pourrait
le voir aussi autour de la Russie bien
sûr qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour le
troisième d cette très grande fracture
géopolitique
qui s'est ouverte donc ça c'est pour ces
pays évidemment on fait plutôt des prêts
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils sont plus riches
que les pays pauvres et puis derrière la
question que vous posez monsieur
sénateur bien sûr c'est les conséquences
de la crise ukrainienne cette fois sur
les pays pauvres et donc là bien sûr on
est très attentif on est tous très
inquiets sur les questions de sécurité
alimentaire le président de la
République je croyais à annoncé que la
France à la FD mais soutiendrait la
sortie financerait la sortie de de
céréales vers la Somalie où il y a une
crise très aiguë très inquiétante il y a
derrière la question des engrais il y a
derrière la question de chaîne de valeur
plus courte il y a la question de
peut-être de
oui d'un développement endogène
c'est-à-dire que les pays arrivent à
s'approvisionner en ressources
alimentaires en engrais en technologie
plus proche finalement que ce qui est
devenu la mondialisation qui à
l'évidence doit être revue et donc on
bien sûr on peut on doit être un
instrument de cette redéfinition de
façon très très concrète et avec bien
sûr les entreprises françaises les nope
qui sont souvent très adaptés à ces
marchés comme l'a dit le sénateur
cadicap après
bien sûr vous avez posé la question des
d'autres pays émergents avec lesquels
les relations bilatérales sont complexes
difficiles j'ai noté dans la discussion
Turquie Brésil - Chine en particulier
je regrouperais Turquie et Brésil juste
pour
dire d'un mot que le l'essentiel de ce
que fait l'Agence française de
développement en Turquie comme au Brésil
n'est pas avec le gouvernement central
en fait en Turquie par exemple 75% de
nos financements passent par les
municipalités le secteur privé les
banques publiques d'autres acteurs
d'autres emprunteurs finalement que que
le gouvernement et donc je pense encore
une fois
infinie tout ça est un choix politique
donc
il appartient aux autorités politiques
de décider si la FD à un mandat en
Ukraine un mandat en Turquie mandat en
Chine ou pas mais je pense qu'on est un
instrument qui permet à notre pays de
tisser des liens de repérer de la
compagnie des acteurs de façon assez
profonde
au-delà des relations d'État en fait en
tout cas c'est très frappant au Brésil
par exemple depuis l'élection du
président bolsonaro la FD fait beaucoup
de financement plus même qu'avant mais
le fait avec les États fédérés
brésiliens qui vous savez d'ailleurs
sont souvent
politiquement d'un autre bord et donc
évidemment je pense je ne sais pas ce
qui se passera au Brésil mais nous
pouvons jouer ce rôle un peu
contracyclique je dirais ou
complémentaire du rôle que joue dans nos
ambassades bien sûr et nos liens
politiques sur la Chine
évidemment j'ai trop peu de temps et on
en a déjà parlé d'ailleurs dans dans
plusieurs auditions bon le mandat fixé
par le gouvernement rediscuter
périodiquement la dernière fois elle
était 2020 au conseil d'administration
de l'AFD c'est un mandat très clair
c'est un mandat sur le deuxième objectif
de la loi c'est-à-dire bien publicment
duo c'est-à-dire nous on est en Chine
pour ce qui nous concerne c'est à dire
le climat et la biodiversité
exclusivement on l'est évidemment par
des projets concrets souvent avec des
PME françaises d'ailleurs je me souviens
d'en avoir visité qui font d'ailleurs
des innovations
qu'elles aimeraient ramener en France je
me souviens d'un dirigeant de PME qui
m'expliquait ça dans le bus là
en Chine donc ça m'avait ça m'avait
intéressé sur un financement de l'AFD on
le fait évidemment avec zéro coup
budgétaire c'est-à-dire il n'y a pas
d'argent du contribuable français dans
les financements que nous en Chine on
lève de l'argent sur les marchés j'avais
la maladresse d'ailleurs je me souviens
quelques années de dire que parfois cet
argent était chinois
j'ai eu tort
voilà enfin c'était juste pour vous
expliquer à l'époque que c'était
finalement
par certains aspects de l'argent chinois
qui étaient réinvestis en Chine avec des
intérêts français c'était cette formule
que j'avais trouvé maladroitement bref
en tout cas évidemment il n'y a pas
d'argent du contribueur français dans
dans nos activités et puis je crois
qu'on fait des bons projets on a on a
discuté d'ailleurs en conseil
d'administration monsieur le ministre
récemment une évaluation de de la somme
des projets qu'on a fait depuis une
dizaine d'années en Chine et cette
évaluation elle est à votre disposition
elle est publique elle est bonne donc
ayant dit ça il suffit pas de faire de
mon projet
on est évidemment un élément de la
relation bilatérale entre la Chine et la
France dans le président encore fixé la
ligne récemment devant les ambassadeurs
et donc c'est aux politiques infin
de décider de notre notre mandat sur le
dialogue social j'ai bien entendu ce que
vous m'avez dit je l'ai entendu
d'ailleurs aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
la vérité c'est effectivement c'était un
peu lié à la fin de mon deuxième mandat
j'ai un peu pressé le pas en fin de
mandat parce que je pense que c'est
l'intérêt c'était nécessaire pour
l'agence dont le corps social qui a
recruté
près de 2000 personnes quand même avec
qui il y a désormais deux filiales qui
ont des métiers très différents des
modèles économiques très différents oui
de mettre un peu plus de diversité dans
le cadre social de l'agence et d'y
mettre aussi un certain nombre
d'incitations qui sont plus alignés sur
la stratégie fixé par les autorités
politiques retranscrites ensuite dans le
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens et le
plan stratégique je crois qu'on l'a fait
encore une fois je vous le redis le
dialogue social a pu être tendu mais il
n'est pas rompu pas du tout je l'ai
encore vérifié avant de vous voir hier
en recevant toutes les organisations
syndicales et maintenant qu'on est
revenu dans l'entreprise je prends
l'engagement devant vous évidemment si
vous me faites confiance que vous n'en
sentiez plus parler et que
nous transformions nous poursuivions
cette grande transformation qui est très
exigeante de cette façon j'ajoute un
point sur le dialogue social dont je
suis très fier
l'AFD à ma connaissance la seule entité
qui a donné une voix dans le dialogue
social à ces agents de droit local nous
avons créé une un comité des
représentants des représentants des
États étrangers où nous aiguisons et le
corps électoral c'est nos agents de
droit local qui n'ont pas le droit
d'être représentés dans le CSE sans le
CSE de l'entreprise ils viennent à Paris
deux fois par an et il nous exprime leur
revendications et leur voix aussi parce
qu'ils ont un jugement une appréciation
sur le fonctionnement de l'agence qui
est singulier singulière et qui est
précieuse et donc on a comme ça une dans
le dialogue social une diversité qui à
ma connaissance dans des institutions
aussi internationales que l'AFD n'existe
nulle part ailleurs et on l'a créé je
dirais sans obligation juridiques c'est
pas dans le droit du travail mais on l'a
fait et on en est on en est je crois
très très heureux le lien avec le
Parlement pour terminer avant peut-être
de les points plus précis donc je le
redis
notre grande disponibilité à renforcer
ses liens toujours plus donc plus de
plus de redevabilité peut-être on
pourrait imaginer un canal d'information
aussi plus un peu plus direct pour que
vous ayez connaissance des actions des
évaluations des projets de l'agence
forme d'une lettre peut-être d'une
information j'ai lu le livre d'Eric
Lombard le directeur général de la
Caisse des dépôts qui exprime sa grande
satisfaction de venir en audition devant
alors la commission des finances les
commissions des finances de façon plus
régulière peut-être que je ne le fais et
pas dans le seul monde dans la
discussion de la loi de finances
c'est-à-dire de venir peut-être une
autre fois parler de l'agence parler de
développement donc évidemment je
répondrai à ces invitations si si vous
le si vous le souhaitez et on pourrait
les préparer peut-être par aussi des
réunions de travail périodiques avec
d'abord me semble-t-il vous rapporter
mais peut-être ouverte ouverte à tous ou
vous ne verriez peut-être pas que moi
mais aussi Marie-Hélène Loison est là
les collègues de l'agence plus plus
experts que moi il faut bien le dire sur
les questions que vous avez soulevées et
qui vous préoccupent les visites de
terrain conjointe je partage la vie de
madame la sénatrice c'est formidable moi
je si on peut systématiser ça si vous le
souhaitez c'est très heureux et la vie
sur les stratégies me semble très
intéressant je serai preneur aussi
là aussi monsieur Patriat l'a dit
l'agence est connue on fait des sondages
chaque année la notoriété de l'agence
c'est les gens disent un Français sur
deux la connaissent bon quand on regarde
plus précisément on s'est plutôt 10%.
donc et 10% c'est les gens qui aiment
l'aide au développement c'est les gens
c'est plutôt des CSP plus enfin les donc
on a un vrai sujet de au-delà de oui
j'en ai entendu parler de monter les
gens qui nous connaissent vraiment et
qu'ensuite ça diffuse plus fortement
donc je serai très preneur aussi d'un
échange sur la stratégie de
communication de l'agence avec vous
évidemment qui savait mieux mieux que
moi la façon de d'atteindre les
Françaises et les Français et en
particulier notre jeunesse sur ce point
donc peut-être voilà quelques quelques
éléments qui pourraient permettre outre
les évaluations monsieur le Président là
aussi on peut venir vous présenter des
évaluations si vous le souhaitez comment
on le fait au conseil d'administration
maintenant très régulièrement
sur les si j'ai encore le temps sur le
président
en passant rapidement dans vos questions
pour monsieur guerriot je crois avoir
répondu on sera à Abidjan avec toutes
ces banques publiques du 18 au 20
octobre prochain on espère faire en
Amérique latine sous président espagnol
de l'Union européenne
le sommet l'année suivante c'est un
sujet géostratégique à mon avis majeur
qui souffre peut-être d'un trop faible
investissement aujourd'hui l'agence
c'est 2 milliards d'euros
d'investissements d'Amérique latine
chaque année on y est accumulé beaucoup
d'expérience qu'on souhaite renforcer
encore pour Madame Carlotti non la FD
c'est l'inverse de la France africain ça
l'a toujours été
j'évoque les mannes de André postal
Vinet et de tous nos grands anciens
ils se sont construits en partie contre
ça clairement j'ai moi-même publié
récemment
un livre avec le l'historien philosophe
Achille BMB qui je crois est très
explicite sur sur ce point dans le
travail car engager le président de la
République de renouvellement de
redéfinition évidemment complexe de
notre relation avec l'Afrique qui est
une très grande une très grande priorité
près dont
je crois que je vous ai dit les prêts
c'est bien aussi je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur je regardais ça permet de
passer à l'échelle et puis c'est plus
économe de l'argent du contribuable
quand même pour et ça atteinte dès lors
que c'est des prêts d'une banque
publique c'est-à-dire avec les listes
d'interdiction les priorités le filtre
qui assure la même qualité finalement
que ce qu'on peut faire avec des dons la
société civile encore une fois quand je
suis arrivé en 2016 c'était 65 millions
les financements de la FD vers la
société civile on est à 165 millions on
a cette cible d'augmenter encore et puis
ce que j'ai fait c'est au-delà du
guichet que je mesure ici on travaille
maintenant beaucoup plus avec la société
civile dans le reste des projets de la
FD et donc quand on a une réunion
annuelle avec Coordination SUD pour
faire le point en fait le les
financements de la FD tous instrument
confondus parfois des prêts d'ailleurs
qui sont mis en oeuvre ensuite par des
organisations de la société civile c'est
plutôt de l'ordre de 500 millions en
fait aujourd'hui et je ne vois pas de
raison de ne pas continuer à augmenter
cette part d'ailleurs évidemment que nos
partenaires mettent en œuvre selon les
critères avec l'exigence que nous
souhaitons ça contribue aussi à
renforcer on a aussi ouvert le guichet
société civile cette année pour la
première fois aux organisations de la
société civile du Sud alors qu'il était
vous le savez réservé aux organisations
aux ONG françaises donc on fait ça aussi
prudemment et ça suppose d'augmenter
probablement la taille de ce de ce
guichet mais je crois que c'est une
évolution intéressante et le
gouvernement aussi souhaité l'ouvrir aux
acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donc là aussi qu'ils ont
plutôt nationaux mais qui pour certains
d'entre eux veulent développer aussi une
une activité internationale sur le
l'égalité femme homme on a des
instruments spécifiques pour renforcer
les associations féministes du Sud donc
on a un fond notamment où il y a 40
millions d'euros il va falloir le
recompléter bientôt donc on a on a à
votre disposition beaucoup d'actions
auprès de d'ONG de défenseuse des droits
des femmes c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
parce que leur voix est pas forcément la
même que celle des associations en
France parce qu'elles partent évidemment
d'un contexte différent je pense qu'il y
a beaucoup à apprendre aussi de la façon
dont ces femmes et ces hommes font
progresser l'égalité de droit et plus
globalement le chiffre de 50% que
j'indiquais en fait c'est vous savez les
marqueurs de l'OCDE 4 1 4 2 dans notre
horrible jargon c'est à dire les projets
qui ont un effet soit direct soit
indirect à ces quatre-2 dont on peut
mesurer l'impact pour l'égalité fameux
c'est comme pour le climat ça veut pas
dire que les 50 autres pour cent sont
mauvais mais c'est c'est les
financements sur lesquels on est capable
de rendre des comptes et de mesurer que
ça a une contribution positive et ça on
a beaucoup augmenté là aussi et le cadre
1 qui est le plus difficile on est à peu
près à 800 millions au-delà des
objectifs du COM et le 4 2 évidemment
qui est plus dans d'autres projets où on
ajoute la dimension la dimension de
genre
monsieur patria j'ai répondu je crois et
sur les sondages et sur l'Ukraine
monsieur Launay
alors oui on est 28e sur 50 au
classement pubish what you fun la
tendance est bonne quand même on a 12
points de plus on a gagné 5 places et
surtout on a changé de catégorie comme
je l'ai dit on est passé dans la
catégorie bonne good donc on est très
clairement en progrès dans ce domaine il
y a une limite ça c'est une limite qui
dépend de vous d'ailleurs c'est que
l'AFD est soumise par exemple ou à la
loi bancaire et au secrétaire et donc
ceux qui sont tout en tête du classement
de la transparence c'est des
institutions multilatérales qui n'ont
pas ce type de contrainte légale en fait
donc on va progresser on va continuer on
y travaille on a un plan d'action on
sera probablement jamais premier dans
cette liste j'en suis j'en suis désolé
je vous remercie évidemment pour votre
témoignage trop parcours à doubler de
taille aussi des six dernières années
donc l'axe développement économique
secteur privé est évidemment très très
prioritaire je l'ai dit aussi dans mon
propos madame Duranton les fonds propres
il y a deux déterminants il y a ce qu'on
appelle le ratio de solvabilité donc il
faut pas
il faut avoir
11,75% de son bilan fonds propres dur on
a une petite décote on veut 13,25 nous
donc ça on y vaille très attentivement
et puis ce qui est le plus mordant pour
nous c'est ce qu'on appelle le ratio des
grands risques c'est à dire vous n'avez
pas le droit d'avoir plus de quart de
votre de vos fonds propres sur un seul
client et donc quand vous êtes aussi
actif que nous le sommes auprès du
gouvernement du Maroc par exemple
périodiquement la FD tangente ce niveau
de d'ailleurs nous on prend pas 25% on
prend 23% pour être un peu avoir un
petit peu de marge on tamponne un peu ce
niveau et d'où la nécessité
périodiquement en tout cas de
renforcer les fonds propres de l'agence
elle l'a fait depuis 1941 par ses
résultats en fait elle avait jamais été
recapitalisée et c'est vrai que ce
gouvernement depuis 2017 à
rehausser de 4 milliards le niveau des
fonds propres bon là on est normalement
à peu près bien pour faire 12 milliards
par an s'il y a une ambition
supplémentaire il faudra aussi revoir le
montant du capital compte tenu de ces
ratios qui sont fixés par la Banque de
France en fait évidemment qui nous qui
nous régule
Monsieur Laurent je crois avoir
répondu à vos points le développement
endogène c'est le développement pour moi
donc c'est c'est évidemment j'ai dit une
agence du côté des autres nous notre
travail a toujours été vous avez les
procédures de l'AFD si jamais la FD qui
fait elle-même en fait sauf vraiment une
exception nous on apporte toujours des
financements à un acteur local ça nous
distingue d'ailleurs très nettement de
l'agence américaine par exemple qui
s'appelle USA vous savez USA a pris
l'engagement de faire passer 30% de ses
financements par des acteurs locaux
aujourd'hui ils sont à 6% et donc j'ai
demandé moi mais que fait l'AFD à mes
équipes et en fait la FDL fait passer
plus de 90% de ses financements par des
acteurs locaux c'est assez logique
d'ailleurs quand on fait des prêts parce
que vous allez pas faire un prêt et
garder l'argent vous même donc ça veut
dire qu'on a depuis très très longtemps
cette volonté ce souhait de faire
confiance et de faire et de renforcer
bien sûr par de la formation de
l'accompagnement les maîtrises
d'ouvrages locales dans tous les pays ou
nous intervenons c'est notre mode de
faire monsieur caddic sur les
entreprises chinoises j'ai évidemment
des chiffres à votre disposition c'est
très très faible dans les financements
de la FD
et bien sûr ces appels d'offres ces
cahiers des charges doivent respecter
l'ensemble des conditions qui incluent
le respect des droits humains ne pas
faire commerce d'armes 9 il y a
évidemment des critères très stricts et
aucune exception faite quelle que soit
le l'entreprise qui gagne le marché j'ai
aussi à votre disposition bien sûr les
chiffres de ce dispositif un peu
expérimental qui avait été mis en place
si Madame madame
la sénatrice en a parlé pour appuyer les
PME frappés par la crise covid avec un
accent particulier une information qui a
été donnée pour les PME
de droits étrangers mais détenus par des
entrepreneurs français on a quasiment
utilisé l'ensemble de la dotation je
pense qu'on a ça a permis de libérer à
peu près 800 millions d'euros on a aidé
je pense à peu près sans entreprise on
l'a fait beaucoup avec la Société
générale dans sept pays sur les 15 où on
a déployé ce mécanisme de garantie
c'était expérimentale donc je pense à un
retour d'expérience un bilan et de voir
si ça peut devenir quelque chose de plus
régulier dans Au-delà du covid dans
l'activité de l'agence serait
certainement
extrêmement intéressant
voilà
je conclue j'ai peut-être oublié
certaines remarques
je conclus monsieur le Président en vous
remerciant en espérant vous avoir
convaincu de ma maîtrise de ces dossiers
de l'agence et
en prenant encore à nouveau devant vous
ces engagements de évidemment de
géopolitique de qualité dans les projets
et de poursuite de la transformation de
l'agence dans le dialogue social tel que
je les ai exprimés merci merci Monsieur
le Directeur général
trois observations pour conclure ce
débat tout d'abord je pense que vous
avez perçu à travers les observations et
les questions de nos collègues notre
volonté de voir la loi du 4 août 21
appliquée parce que les parlementaires
ne travaillent pas quand même pour le
plaisir il travaille pour faire avancer
les choses on a fixé un certain nombre
d'orientations vous les avez rappelé et
notamment sur les grands équilibres sur
les répartitions près dont etc
multilatérales bilatéral je pense que
c'est très important et surtout le
comité d'évaluation car c'était une
volonté très forte du Parlement
Assemblée nationale et Sénat de de
pouvoir participer à l'évaluation d'une
politique qui quand même représente
beaucoup de d'argent dans des temps où
l'argent public est rare donc si le sort
vous est favorable nous serons
évidemment attentifs à ce que c'est toi
soit appliqué je l'ai dit et nous le
redirons ici en commission à la nouvelle
ministre et je pense que c'est aussi sa
volonté un second point je nous ce point
n'a peut-être pas été enfin vous l'avez
abordé vous-même mais je n'oublie pas
qu'ici ce qui n'est pas le cas de
l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes aussi
la commission de la défense et des
forces armées et je souhaite que leur
avenir on est un petit peu plus de
précision sur les actions coordonnées
entre défenses et développement parce
que nous sommes actuellement dans une
situation un peu compliquée on va dire
notamment en Afrique de redéploiement
sur d'autres pays après
le départ du Mali et on a eu quand même
je à le dire beaucoup de témoignages de
la part de nos de nos responsables
militaires disons que la coordination
entre les deux je ne pointe personne du
doigt mais je dis que la coordination
entre les deux n'est pas n'est pas
totalement satisfaisant et je pense
qu'on la France ne peut pas donner dans
les villages dans lequel elle apporte la
sécurité on ne peut pas donner
uniquement l'image de soldats
ressemblant à des robocops et il faut
aussi que derrière il y a des brigades
du développement en quelque sorte qui
viennent conforter parce que c'est
peut-être aussi à cause de ça que
l'image de la France est dégradée parce
qu'au début on arrive comme des
libérateurs et à la fin on finit comme
des occupants et donc je pense qu'il va
falloir faire très attention à ce volet
ça a été rappelé par plusieurs de nos
collègues et on va être assez attentif à
cette dimension en ayant ici la chance
d'être la même commission qui examine
les dessus les deux sujets
c'est un point important enfin je
voudrais réinsister sur ce qu'on dit nos
collègues je pense qu'une institution de
cette importance avec la qualité des
personnels qu'il la composent budget qui
est à votre disposition doit avoir un
dialogue social d'excellence et tout ce
que tout ce qui nous a été rapporté tout
ce que nous avons entendu ne correspond
pas à l'idée que l'on se fait du
fonctionnement de cette agence et je
pense que nos à la fois nos
administrateurs et puis nous nous
rapportaient bien sûr mais veillerons à
ce que cette affaire se résolvent dans
dans le cas des dispositions que vous
avez évoquées ce directeur général nous
allons prendre congé de vous je vais
demander la suspension donc nous allons
prendre congé de ceux qui nous suivent
et qui nous écoutent car la captation va
se terminer donc maintenant avant